The joe rogan experience of Vi red.
Why the worlds?
The opening line is something like,
I can't remember the opening line and I'm paraphrasing.
The earth was B.
We knew we were being watched or what we didn't know was we were being watched
and that's a great opening line for a Scifi novel.
Martians are watching us and then they shunned their ships and everything.
It's a beautiful Scifi novel because it's so precise.
Just Know Sigh.
He made up all the PSI and wells really did make it up like he knew nothing
about technology show.
It's awesome.
You know how the tripods come out of the ships and they have laser beams and
they basically laser beam everything.
Like he just started made APP.
It's going to be this beam of pure energy or whatever.
You know what's fascinating and he did do that,
but that's what a lot of people use as their template for the future.
When they thought about like future weapons,
it was always a laser beam.
It was always a beam.
Well wait,
I think what's,
once physics were understood that things were in particles that wasn't,
that they get jumped,
that there would bitch be,
first of all,
this isn't Zeus.
Is Thunderbolts the ultimate.
Yes.
You know?
Sure,
dude.
Um,
yeah,
just,
I mean,
just thunder in general.
Just the idea of this power,
this electricity for everybody knew what electricity wasn't what it could do.
I would have loved to been alive,
um,
before electricity was explained and see what the fuck people were saying.
You know,
I mean,
could you imagine what people were saying back when,
you know,
people barely had a language they barely could string together a sentence that
you would understand and the fucking sky bolts of come to a sky and hitting the
ground balls of light.
Yeah,
that's true.
Through a field you have to deal with that.
You know,
there's been an instance that I read about,
um,
well of ball lightning.
Like there's been several instances of ball lightning that they think explains
Ufos.
Yeah.
I wouldn't be surprised.
I think that that a lot of,
not all you have,
I was obviously,
but some Ufo sightings,
they talk about these orbs that are flying orbs of light apparently under
certain geological pressures,
like certain pressures on near fault lines and,
and the like,
there's,
there's fucking bolts of lightening that like come out of the ground.
I wouldn't be surprised if,
yeah,
it's supposed to and it can last for like three or four seconds.
We'll,
if everything in the world is an electric charge and everything is totally makes
sense.
Right.
Just a weird spark,
you know,
that occurs.
What is this ball of light and yeah,
mainly exciting.
My wife and I were in a Capri ones and uh,
it's a little island off the coast of Naples.
And is that enough?
Uh,
well I think they're saying this is ball lightning.
Yeah.
That could believe it would be ball lightning cause ball lightning has weird
properties.
Yeah.
Look,
look at that just disappeared.
It's a femoral and it righter than fuck.
So you can see it from miles away.
Right and right.
And you when lightening hits things,
you know how you always see sparks and shit?
Well,
my wife and I were sitting,
we were having dinner and this and it's a little island and a big storm started
brewing on the Mediterranean and all of a sudden everything,
you know,
the ozone in the air and your hair starts to stand up.
And it was a light breeze and Capri smells like Lemons and bay leaves.
So it was really beautiful.
And I said to my wife,
and this is what a rabbit smells like right before the lid comes down on the,
um,
Bailey in Lebanon and hey,
I'm a,
I'm uh,
and then we sat on the balcony of our hotel and the storm never hit Capri,
but it was several miles away and we watched it and it just,
just giant lightening strikes out in the clouds and that it never got close
enough to rain.
You know what I mean?
Oh,
that's great.
And it was,
yeah,
I said,
this is like watching the gods play,
right?
Like here,
we're sitting here with a glass of wine and the air electric and all you,
you'd hear it,
you know,
and then you,
you see it and then you'd hear it afterwards because it was that far away.
Now you need clouds to have light.
Yeah.
And the clouds were just crashing together and it would,
you'd see like,
Shit,
what I'm saying is,
were you were,
you didn't have to worry.
There's no clouds above you.
You didn't have to worry.
We were,
it was at least a couple of miles away.
Wow.
So you don't want to clear sky said it.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
Clear Mediterranean sky simply that you could feel the raised electricity in the
air because there was a breeze blowing end on your hair was on an down and there
was a lot of ozone,
you know,
from all the crashing,
but it never got close enough to never hit the island and never poured rain.
It just sort of stayed right off the island.
And I was like,
that's so exciting.
If I could always have storms to spectate,
you know,
cause she'd watch a ball just like shoot from one cloud to another arcane rope,
and,
and it was endlessly entertaining.
There's nothing more entertaining than lightening,
you know,
the noise of the thunder and that smell of,
especially if you know you're not going to die.
That was what made it so great.
We were sitting there with a joint and a glass of wine.
It was like,
you know,
heavenly cause if you're in a city,
like if you're in New York City,
big no storm goes on.
You have this weird feeling that lightening could hit this fucking building
anytime and my windows could explode.
I was on a plane with my wife going into Frankfurt,
Germany for the World Cup like in 2006 and we flew through a giant electrical
storm.
So we're on the plane and I'm looking out the window and the plane's bouncing up
and down and a giant ball of lightening struck the wing of the plane.
Oh my watch on.
And it went like this and then bang and huge booming noise.
The lights dimmed for a second and went right back on and everyone on the planet
like dot.
Right.
Oh Margo flight attendants went fucking white.
Which then I was a little scared because I thought,
well they shouldn't be freaked out.
Right.
And my wife was panicked.
He and I went,
not that I was so great,
but I went the wing still there.
Let's start there.
The wing,
the wing is completely intact and hit the ball lightning right at the end of
the,
you know,
the little metal thing they have at the end of the one,
they have a metal thing,
uh,
exoskeleton thing around them.
So then lightening hits,
it's disperses around the planet.
So prepare for that.
Obviously you have to write because they're going to fly through electricity
that look at that picture.
Oh my God.
You never hear about planes blowing up because we got hit by,
look at this,
watch this.
Oh that will,
it's crazy.
Cause and then when you see it in real life,
it looks like nothing like so fast.
Yeah.
Let me see what it actually is.
It got hit and then the pilot didn't come off for like 10 minutes.
That rat,
he let us all sweat and everybody was like scared shitless maybe.
Then the pilot came on and he chocolate Kissinger.
He was German obviously,
but he,
he first,
he didn't German than English,
but when he spoke in English she sounded like Kissinger,
the
blood is harmless and everybody was like,
oh my God,
what's going on here?
But it looks scary.
This is the Turkish airplane hit by lightening strike inside playing video,
but I don't know why there was sparks going.
Look at the door.
The doors.
Oh,
they just got hit right there and the lights go out.
Oh my God.
It's terrifying.
The mountains.
Shit's terrifying man.
Shut it off now.
We're going to be nice.
Don't ever put that back on again.
We got to fly everywhere.
I'm flying this weekend.
Let's just collide together and drive.
Come on,
man.
Nah Man.
You know,
flying through the sky where the fucking gods are angry,
I think.
Did I tell you this one?
If I've told it,
I'll stop.
We flied out.
Shalia Kaleah scout and was on a little plane.
Usually you're on a giant plane,
but it was on like a seven 37 you know,
like that Australia.
Yeah,
it was a Virgin Australia,
which is agree with the airline.
So on the flight with me and my wife has a,
the game,
you know the sky is a rapper,
right?
He's got a tattoo on his head,
whatnot and carry Hilden who's also a rapper and a and their posse.
Right?
So it's hectic,
right?
It starts to get the MP and the pilot comes on and goes like everybody strapped
in.
Okay.
For like ever.
And it Australia is 15 hours,
16 minutes long.
It's just the whole day.
And this lasted literally five hours,
right?
Wow.
Just bouncing up and down.
So I decided pitching yard,
the whole thing and on the,
on the sky map,
but it says like Paygo,
Paygo,
1500 kilometers,
meaning your 1500 kilometers from Paco.
Paco.
In other words,
the Pacific Ocean is so big,
there's no land masses,
nothing anywhere near you where you're going over.
Right.
So you're not going to go in because its turbulence,
it's not your fucking freaking me out.
You're not going to die.
This is an electric turbulence,
doesn't make planes crash and it doesn't,
unless there's some sort of Shitty,
a structural defect on the plane like that,
you know,
the wings aren't glued on or whatever.
But I mean videos,
structural defect
generally.
Now you've been in a play turbulence data,
you know,
that's not what makes him crashing,
you know.
But anyways,
uh,
Shit Shit,
it's terrible in any case.
So we get through it and a next morning and the rappers get up and they're all
like,
oh my God,
I thought I was going to die.
And you know,
it was so bad last night I was praying and La,
la,
they're all with really shook up and carry.
Hilton is a,
a very lovely young rapper.
Lady wakes up,
it's been all night.
Mind you,
no one can move.
I stopped holding my wife's hand for five,
you know,
like,
like this for,
you know,
cause like this,
Oh what happened?
And the rappers because you didn't feel that we were going to die that had to
claim it.
But I know that we are and she goes,
I took a pill,
I didn't see anything.
Ambien's a motherfucker get what?
And then she ate one piece of fruit and put on a leopard miniskirt and came out
with her makeup and signed autographs and I was like,
you're a star.
I want you on my team.
You are Alexander the Great,
everyone was scared.
The adrenaline you could smell in the plane,
you know what I mean?
From five hours of bouncing,
you know,
just not,
oh,
you know you want it to stop,
stop bouncing so we can stop producing.
And she just woke up a word.
Yeah.
Fucking put on a pushup bra getting ready to for the photo call when they got
off the plane,
I believe you did tell the story.
I remember [inaudible] herself will Ferrell was like,
you gotta be kidding me man.
Yeah.
It was either Ma this podcast or another podcast.
I heard you tell a story.
I remember it now after it's over.
We talked about the girl getting out and changing.
Yeah,
that's a great story.
Wow.
It's great that someone could be that,
that out cold on ambient.
So there's positive things to ambien.
I was talking about shit about Ambien,
but if ambient can get you to avoid that,
not one minute at that.
And it lasts.
I'm sorry,
I didn't mean to repeat it,
but it always made me laugh because I was scared to death.
And when I got off the plane,
I looked like,
you know,
something James Brolin sat on,
I was squishy and moist.
What's your dance per day?
Yeah.
And you know,
you're just wracked.
Uh,
and all I wanted to do is like,
you know,
eat a club sandwich and die,
cause you're like,
God,
we're on the ground.
And she just like,
Hey,
he's for pictures.